lula va oficialmente por la presidencia
de brasil
el anuncio se dio a conocer en una
convención de la cúpula del partido de
los trabajadores y partidos de coalición
progresistas en la cita también se
aprobó la fórmula vicepresidencial del
candidato de izquierda el liberal
geraldo alckim el país está
experimentando una completa degradación
en todos los aspectos de la vida
nacional en nuestra campaña que decimos
hoy encabezada por lula y al king
es una pieza fundamental para encaminar
al país para traer la garantía de la
institucionalidad democrática a nuestro
país
lula no asistió al evento pero se
manifestó en las redes sociales no
necesitaba volver a ser presidente
podría mantener mi título como el mejor
presidente de la historia e ir a vivir
los últimos años de mi vida en paz pero
vi este país destruido vi la educación
dirigida por un tipo al que no le gusta
la educación así que decidí volver la
mayoría de los sondeos dan como vencedor
al líder sindical frente al actual
mandatario ya ir bolsonaro esta es la
sexta ocasión que lula se lanza en busca
de la presidencia del gigante
suramericano logrando establecerse en el
palacio de planalto en dos ocasiones